je vais laisser tout de suite ma place à
juju combes et je reviendrai à tout à
l'heure il y aura la chronique de
camille combal bien sûr mais là je dois
partir pour ma mission à france
télévisions on va tenter l'impossible on
a on a prévu un zodiac on va partir au
zodiac avec camille combal
on va aller devant france télévisions
leur a préparé quelque chose on va aller
voir les salariés de france télévisions
est ce que je peux vous dire on est le
1er avril qui dit première avril 10
poissons qui dit poissons dits sardines
on va y aller on va leur montrer ce que
sarah france télévisions
m
aidez-vous camille combal et camille
combal aînés ou en camion va le
rejoindre à laisser partir alors allez-y
faites votre émission peu le bon truc à
nous on y va à s'annuler gamma
des gens fait pour pas tout
ça les gens sont comme ça que ça marche
d'habitude est parti alors on va faire
un petit point me dit oh en régie pour
voir où et cyril il part je vous le
rappelle en zodiac à france 2 pour aller
rencontrer ses futurs employés je ne
sais pas s'il nous entend voilà il
arrive donc le long de la seine et bien
aux diagnostics devrait selon tutu au 10
janvier
on va arriver sur le bateau là c'est une
péniche autant d'eau que d'eau brière
qui devait arriver le volet à sauter là
elle légale et gassin beaux bateaux qui
nous aident les gars le seul prix
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait ça a beau s à
vos bateaux qui nous ont bien je peux
vous dire donc là il faut qu on saute on
saute et jaune ils savent asie après moi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai pas envie qu'on perd 10 a basé mon
chéri en salle à cela
[Applaudissements]
oui moi d sahara
ça va c'est dans carrie bocaly est avec
toi l'imago garde fonctionne il fait
gaffe à belmondo sega tient c'est bon
vas-y vas-y et bravo c'est le seul qui a
réussi à s'imposer tient donc à vie
allez on attend le début de la traversée
vous larguer les amarres on attend le
début de sa valeur ces séries de quatre
heures allez devrait dépasser bon on va
y aller on va traverser au valhalla
france télévisions c'est un rêve qui se
réalise assez génial et qui est interdit
tu connais plutôt sur la bon soir ça
vient france télévisions si vous perdez
pas si les plages aux touristes groupe
les verts allez c'est parti la traversée
de redire et consomment pas de minutes
on regarde quand même à les laisser en
essais suivront six leçons décrochera
pas plus
mais
cyril sirgent est entendu en reste avec
vous parce qu'a toujours le son ça vaut
le coup dressé avec vous en 3 et sans
bfm a meublé
c'est vrai c'est vrai regardez jeunes
acheter une voiture regarder merci c'est
magnifique ça fait 17 ans
bonjour les gars les gars ça bouge
beaucoup la caméra 5
j'ai fait contrepoids au boulot sur toi
tu te remets pas bien alors on n'est pas
bien tu là oui les mecs arrivent dans
l'île de la tentation mais on dirait
qu'on a fait des mecs c'est lille celi
le doigt de télé des de la détonation
regardez mon équipe donc de regarder
l'équipe franchement il faudrait le
nouvel épisode on évoque son mari mon
bateau là on va se mettre à poil à la
demande des soldats français
la france télévisions regarder ou
vacances à tous
[Applaudissements]
très vite avec un épisode la sofcot et
vous allez voir ce qu attend à france
télévisions kaboul la tête de france
télé oui c'est à putsch qui se prépare à
tout de suite sur des buts petit robert
cyril est parti conquérir ses futurs
salariés en tant que président c ries
président est bien à traverser la seine
il est hors jeu bien qu'avec son
directeur de campagne sont des métiers
series de tableau réside à juin
saleh au là on arrive qu'on arrive à à
france télévisions regarder ya comité
d'accueil pour tous à jeddah
[Applaudissements]
jt de david pujadas donc on va essayer
d'y aller voilà kabila je vais pas sir
du bachot vais passer monsieur candidats
j'allais à les y attendait qu'on
n'oublie pas et ça quand même
oui ça arrive à ma chérie on et diana
je pars tu les passions et ça c'est bon
ça passe ou ça passe ça y est bon juste
après val à france télévisions va
demander à faire donc j'étais david
pujadas
bien sûr c'est important
julia entretenu dans un accord devant
les masques les on arrive on arrête
toute l'équipe
on arrive avec toute l'équipe de zana
store moi je sus on va essayer de faire
le jt david pujadas vous pouvez leur
arrivée on se retrouve dans une minute
ça y est on est en vendée un rendement
france télévisions voyais mon directeur
de coop réd 4 qui par la traîne
vous savez que ce parc a dit ce n'est
pas vraiment son truc donc yaya bon qu
il y avoue direct dans la coquette qui
est très loin et là il sort alors
qu'abby qu'à des dommages y en a eu mais
regardez le chercher il a couru le 100 m
il a explosé le mercato et issife et la
voiture balai hidary blessé de juin
alors on va essayer de rentrer en france
télévisions et de faire le jt de david
pujadas d'accord à la main regardez
regardez il ya des gens france télé qui
nous regardent qu'il nous faudrait
coucou
ça sent très bien dans cette affaire
[Applaudissements]
chaque année chardy a calé
bizot c'est notre nouvelle maison
on m'a sonné on a sonné président on va
recelait a priori jean todt les
personnes non ouais les personnes de
nous voir à plus regardé personne moi
[Musique]
c'est le petit nom pour la sentra de
décocher notre entrée regardé hier
monsieur qui va venir nous parler
et apparemment il est très sympathique
il faudra il est sympa mais pour l'as tu
veux pas nous parler on va essayer de
rentrer on a le droit de rentrer
monsieur le président wade
on va rentrer au fera le jt de david
pujadas en plus elle est con harvey dent
tout à leur folle parce qu'il ya camille
combal kahn qui a préparé une chronique
donc il va quand même la faire je le
ferai de la scène rentrée ou vraiment à
cette [ __ ] de ça
via l'interface à une interface à
l'interphone attendant l'appel pour
entrer il a bien se fout ici julien on
embrasse qui devait en tout cas jamais
ça ceux pour qui devait julien vas-y
vas-y on entend depuis que j'aimerais
bien qu'elle mène mademoiselle valérie
on va vous la mettre au fond le maître
s'en plaindre
julie a continué c'est quoi la suite
allait alors oui bonjour c'est cyril
hanouna
oui oui elle pouvait pas ouvrir juste à
moi il faut que je parle faut que je
veux venir juste voir les locaux pour
moi si nous changeons le lino pas de
l'entrée côté lyon a de l'autre côté je
veux passer du côté de l'autre côté et
de l'autre côté là d'accord et de
l'autre côté je peux passer
je vais tâcher senoussi d'eric
[Rires]
reconnu sébastien folin à d'accord alors
on va faire le tour on va essayer de
passer par le côté mots je jure par le
parking de l'autre côté bien sûr donc
une deuxième entrée ou à mon avis ça va
être compliqué mais on va quand même
essayer puis il ya plein de choses vous
avez vu c'est génial parce que plein de
gens qui ont l'habitude sera regardée et
qui ne sont pas entrain deux bouts c'est
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe si si mais
louis mecheri mes chiens on est de
l'autre côté de france 2 ça m'a lâché à
duda président ou la présidente
voilà c'est pas et on le sent bien en
ouverture et l'année prochaine en prête
l'intention bercy à la diva au nul à
saint georges de beauce tard voilà ça me
change de motards
on joue bach
ouais j'suis là oui on te suisse et les
etats unis avancent avance parce que
julien sailly en va ici on va on va
essayer de rentrer chez eux car le
monsieur bonsoir monsieur ça revient
c'est bon on est mort là c'est mort ces
morts alors monsieur vous êtes content
que ce soit votre nouveau patron n'en
voulez pas regarder ils sont côte à
regarder regardez regardez attentivement
les républicains public arrive on va
essayer de rétro très bas à julien
de toutes les façons on va paix le
président le président en exercice a
tout eu pour jeunes actifs de millas
combien d'entrer à france 2 c'est déjà
la troisième
nous en sommes à la 25e entrée était pas
content à le monsieur qu'on le filme
alors oh non on est en train de le
donner coachella
s'il vous plaît monsieur je vous êtes en
flammes non à la magie est ce que vous
pouvez laisser lantin suivi la
praticienne gt2 50 tôt
hélas ce dossier non
regardez première déjà
sélectionné je suis tout seul je veux
d'avoir la vie je viens en habitation
vous inquiétez pas dû la j'ai repéré les
deux trois personnes voilà vous
inquiétez pas on sera prendre les
mesures nécessaires si l'os mais ils ont
l'air sympa quand même ils veulent pas
nous laisser rentrer oui on a
rendez-vous avec roger zabel civile tous
se voient la bombe à julien j'ai
l'impression qu'on va revenir en zodiac
a essayé de revenir vitesse en moto sans
audience pour la fin parce que tu ne
laisses un patient c'est vous qui voulez
voir nos pages avoir qui devait vous
inquiétez pas il y aura il y aura un
morceau de la chronique
allez vous m'appelez dès que j'ai quand
même un truc de fou
v
j'aurai je rêve et une émission touche
pas à mon poste les plus improbables -
non mais là on sait maintenant vous
savez c
[Applaudissements]
à mon jeu
je
oh non pas voulu laisser entrer ok on va
la jouer comme ça mais la prochaine fois
on y retournera
mais c'est vrai j'ai déjà un plan j'ai
déjà un plan vous inquiétez pas je pense
qu'ils vont pas reconnaître sébastien
folin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]